[Music]
the big ones have really kind of drive
home about this game in particular is it
is David versus Goliath the elephant in
the room
everybody thinks Empire is gonna win
that's the way that it looks like this
one is going to go up the story is how
say that the invited team versus the
team no one thought would make it this
far we're trying to finally understand
whether these guys have what it takes to
play with the big boys for us it was
like we were the last hope to sort of go
hey don't count a back out yet we're
still working through it I hope that
this event has been an eye-opener a pact
that if they're not doubling down then
we might not be able to be the only one
holding on to them for long
joystick Falls and only one left they
said it couldn't be done but it Stan
trudges on in through the smoke one HP's
got three kills to find and it's it's
Dundee it's Crocodile Dundee Michael oh
my goodness I can't get over this tank
who's their lusty cutout so damaged
under the coil around the corner
who's better lust is that fanatic is the
first team to take out g2 at the six
Invitational oh my god Maggie's hidden
they go right behind the clash as well
and they can defuse from it does he have
the egg chili
[Applause]
[Applause]
what the hell is that in the playoffs of
this year's r6 Invitational fnatic stood
alone as the sole a pack squad amongst
many EU na and Brazilian teams for us it
was like we were the last hope to sort
of go hey don't count a pack out yet
we're still working through it compared
to other major regions a pack has always
been considered weak in siege coming up
against fnatic a reach from a pack a
region that without really shaming
anyone too hard probably isn't one of
the more competitive regions around the
world right now despite coming from a
week of region fnatic has always managed
to play well against other powerhouse
areas of the world now the only team I
think you will find across the entirety
of the roster of teams that are here at
the 6th Invitational where every single
player has a positive KD yes they're a
good team they're on a reach and again
where a lot of the teams around them and
nowhere near as competitive as what you
will find elsewhere but you definitely
can't dismiss them as being a bunch of
good players from an outside perspective
in a packed team making it out of groups
might seem incredible but fnatic always
have bigger goals than that I think like
you said consistency for us as a
double-edged sword we've had that
consistency in terms of we always
qualify for the events and people go
well you know you go through a pack
that's expected but through the
invitationals I think consistently we
also have extremely tough groups and
that's why mentalist in tax come in
there have been two major changes to our
team since everyone has lost seen us
compete we have techs and Mentalist Tex
is fulfilling a flex Fraga role while
mentalist
is sort of fulfilling more of a support
flex role they have been fitting in
really well for our team and definitely
in my opinion I believe this is the
strongest fanuc lineup yeah despite a
new buffed up roster with Mentalist and
text fnatic we're still giant underdogs
coming into the invitation the big ones
are really kind of drive home about this
game in particular is it is David versus
Goliath the elephant in the room
everybody thinks Empire is gonna win
that's the way that it looks like this
one is going to go and I can't say that
I have any different but you know what I
mean but I see my just up a little
surprised of the sleeve here while
fnatic lost and
it was all a part of their risky plan a
plan that nobody expected a team to try
at the biggest tournament of the year so
a first game in our group was against
Empire we're kind of playing a long kong
in for this match
first we lost the Empire we knew they
were very strong and Bank so since we
lost that map on coastline we we knew
that we were probably going to lose the
rest of a match our goal was to not show
much so we can win against face or
dancer but in the deciding match of the
group stage fnatic got revenge on Empire
and knocked out the Russians favorites
and what's arguably the biggest upset in
siege history and they did it in their
own unique style joystick Falls the only
one left they said it couldn't be done
but it's Dan trudges on in through the
smoke one HP's got three kills to find
and it's it's Dundee it's Crocodile
Dundee Michael oh my goodness I can't
get over this fnatic will stun everybody
watching in utter disbelief Empire goes
out in groups absolutely as you said
stunning victory for fnatic they take a
to O over empire but fnatic weren't done
yet
next up they had to beat one of the most
dangerous teams in siege history g2
obviously they've struggled a bit in the
recent past these are the guys that were
two-time Invitational champions coming
into this with the invite of all things
because for some reason they've just
been struggling so much they can't make
it but you know why they get the invite
not just because they're the reigning
champions of the of the invite but also
because they show up at Lance sure g2
had a rough few months but they were
still back-to-back SI champions Penghu
and Fabien had never lost a match at the
invitational if fnatic weren't careful
they could be thrown straight to the
loser's bracket but thank who's their
lusty cutout sub damaged under the coil
around the corner
who's better watch this
fanatic is the first team to take out g2
at the 6:00 Invitational after repeated
top eight finishes fnatic finally
managed to break the top six beating two
of the game's greatest teams along the
way sure they weren't able to advance to
the top four but what fnatic
accomplished is crazy for an AIPAC team
that made roster changes less than three
months ago they're not losers even
though they lost this team they're
really good I really love the team
change that they had bringing in text
mentalist did a fantastic job but
looking into the future what's the
expectations for this team now that
they've made it this far six
invitational looking forward into 2020 I
think we expect them to remain the
number one AIPAC team I'm potentially
push internationally further for those
championships
just because fnatic had an incredible
Invitational run doesn't suddenly mean
AIPAC is gonna be some great region but
fnatic showed the world that there's
hope that with all of the resources
Ubisoft is pouring into the region for
year five one day an AIPAC team could
also raise that hammer and be called
champions thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
you